let me ask you a question do you think
he black you think them your people for
the knot
[Music]
to forget that
[Applause]
[Music]
the streets are war zone
you'll bloom now
I gotta mean to see I go stay in the car
[Music]
this you already got rid of everyone
that could talk
the hell are you doing here rookies
relax all cops here this isn't what it
looks
to do that a body cam on but we got a
ghost she's gone
I think side and you gonna bring
undermine that a night while you're here
let's get you out of here we got her
don't be stupid
all he wants is the body camp
we have been shot what you can't be in
here with this the police they'll help
it was the cops they shot me she cannot
get back to the precinct to upload the
footage on that camera the cop in
criminal in this city is coming to find
her got a price on your head what you
gonna do I'm gonna expose them
he races
all that is be for nothing
this is your plan
[Music]
we're still alive are we
we've got a hard choice to make right
now are you one of us
she picked herself
murder is murder don't matter who you
are my angel
you